foreign
how are you we're great man how are you
well better than I deserved outstanding
outstanding what's up man
well I'm a I was just reaching out I'm a
little discouraged right now with um
um
home ownership and eventually getting to
the point of buying a house
um
I'm I'm currently on the plan and I'm
not too soon to finish up baby step two
but soon enough but I'm just I'm a
teacher and it's the the salary versus
the home prices in the area it's just
really discouraging to
know if I will ever be able
to own a home
yeah no I hear you
um so what how old are you James
I'm 30. 30 okay and how much do you make
a year
between my teaching job and all of my
other jobs right at 60. okay
and we'll put our not what part of
Knoxville are you in
the South area okay that's Knoxville
yeah so what are what are homes going
for down there right now
well looking within the area
um
I'm going to say reasonably about 300
000. okay
do you have a family
I do not no man
great well
um I mean I can I can share in the
frustration of the market I mean it's
been a wacky a few years for housing
it's it's stabilized uh which is which
is great but also uh the values and
everything are up obviously interest
rates are are higher than what they were
at two percent uh back in the day so so
I understand the frustration and the
hard thing is James when it comes to
money
and looking at what you can't afford is
it's really looking at the math and John
talks a lot about this that that facts
are your friends and even though we have
emotions around things whether it's
talking to an 18 year old and they want
to go to a private out of state college
but they can't afford it they're they're
frustrated about that and I get that
they don't have to choose a different
option right so uh so what I would say
to you James is that I don't think that
it's not out it's not out of the picture
I mean making 60 Grand is you're doing
great and you know you're single so even
what type of house or type of living
situation residents you're looking at
you're looking at you know you could
even open up the doors options of a town
home you know owning some type of real
estate is a great goal to have for your
overall Financial picture so I would
continue
to tell you to to go there it may take
you longer to save up a five ten percent
down payment for something but I
wouldn't take it completely out of the
question but where you're looking and
the type of home you're looking at may
have to shift that expectation May shift
which is frustrating and that's not fun
and all that but I think
the reality of which of what you're
where you're at is is what you have to
focus on so James
um tell me if if this is part of of the
frustration too
my dad was was a policeman
and I remember the frustration this was
he never said this out loud but it was
just in the air of our home
this idea that our local community paid
policemen so poor
that he was took a job with public
service and didn't have enough money
barely had enough money to buy a house
and and we struggled with groceries
sometimes and we had a one-car house
it's like we live this extravagant Crazy
Life
and then brother I was a public school
teacher for a few years in Texas
I couldn't have bought a house and that
was before the numbers went crazy
and I remember that same sense of I went
to college I got a degree I'm a teacher
and I can't buy a home like I remember
that haunting my wife was a teacher for
years that same thing so part of that
frustration right is going to be I did
everything right yeah yeah the overall
choices and I can't afford to live in my
own Community right is that some of this
James
that is part of it yes yes and I you
know it wasn't always this way no it
wasn't it wasn't it it wasn't and even
looking at
um going back to Rachel looking at Town
Homes you can't even find a town home
for a decent price yeah everything in
the area
they get goggled gobble up for college
students
um
Rachel's right and I hate to be I hate
to I hate to Second her on this one
is we can't get a pass on math
and so the
questions you have to answer that nobody
can answer for you are
is this the career path forward for you
or am I gonna have to commute a little
bit further because I was put on Earth
to be a teacher
or I'm going to take my skills that I've
developed over the last X number of
years as a teacher and I'm going to
apply them in this setting instead of
this setting
um but the math part doesn't change and
those are all questions we don't want to
answer we don't like those they're not
fun like they they weren't they weren't
part of the the script we were given in
high school and we were told if you just
go to college and get a degree
everything's gonna be a fine
um that wasn't part of the script and so
I think it's having that honest
conversation with yourself and
recognizing how long have you been on
baby step two man
um
probably a little over a year dude
you're at Beatdown stage
you work all these extra jobs and you're
a teacher and you're exhausted and
you're so tired it wasn't even worth
failing a couple of those kids because
you don't want the paperwork and the
fights with the principal you're all of
that and trying to pay debt off and you
see there's no shiny new things there's
no going out to eat you're at the
frustrating part of baby step two right
uh I could I could agree with that
I could agree with that I absolutely
could yeah so I guess at the end of the
day I wish there was a magic pill Rachel
that we could give people like James you
know and I know the Knoxville area so
I'm thinking like the Powell area South
Doyle I mean like there's there's places
James of of just and again if it means
driving another 20 minutes
uh that may be it and that's and that's
the frustrating thing about the whole
housing conversation jobs and you're not
the only one we've had this conversation
with and our own team has experienced
this as they're trying to find houses
like I get it it's so it's so annoying
to think gosh 2019 was just a different
world uh that we live in versus today
what I could have gotten versus what I
do now and it's just all it is this
um it's this level of grappling with
reality that you have to be able to say
okay if I want this I have to believe I
can and not in some like fairy tale way
naive way but to be able to like I
really am going to lay out a plan
between now and the next five years that
I have a goal to own something within
real estate so what does that look like
does that mean changing possibly
changing careers does that mean looking
and broadening where I'm looking uh
because I really I I have confidence
James that you can do this because we
talk to people on the show all the time
that make these decisions but it's not
overnight and like John said where you
are in the process you're in a hard spot
and you still baby step 3 to save up for
an emergency fund right so you're still
years out for this and the world could
look a whole lot different in four years
James when you're actually seriously
looking at purchasing something or
starting to save for it so
um give yourself some time it is a
marathon this whole thing it is it is
years it's not this instance
um effect that you're gonna have these
new results overnight it's just not and
I wish we did have a oh yeah oh man
that's what's frustrating about this
industry is I feel like there are things
out there that are like flashy and like
oh just do this and this and this and
this and people get into those things
thinking they're going to get a quick
turn
and then they get screwed and they lose
money so it's like this is the smartest
wisest path but it's slow James it's
slow and it's and I get it it's not fun
but um one of the cornerstones of
emotional health one of the cornerstones
of relational health is owning reality
just choosing reality here is where we
are and as hard as that is I promise
that the work your body is doing trying
being frustrated about this and being
mad about that and wishing for this that
energy spent is energy that could be
going into solving a real challenge for
you so if your marriage is sideways
avoiding the conversation does not heal
that yeah
um
being a world-class teacher in a great
part of the country
that doesn't change the math of I want
to own a home so like Rachel said okay
five years what's it going to take for
me to do from here to there five years
and I'm gonna just Echo this too John
because we feel this in our County here
in Nashville how frustrating it is that
teachers aren't paid what they should
what they're worth I know and they can't
even live in the county that they teach
like that's all you legislators who are
just throwing sand at each other in your
sandbox Pay Teachers and cops for God's
sakes good grief